[Musik]
mit
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur seite gibt eine
richtig tolle sommer tourte mit trommeln
und aprikosen und ich finde sie sieht
aus wie noch mal vor bislang ist also
krieg also alles auswirkungen hat
insofern genau bodenwellen aprikosen im
innern habe ich ein bisserl und haben
der macht ab ohne quarkcreme das ganze
ist ein bisschen marmoriert und ich hab
noch kleine amara phoenix mit dabei und
ich glaube die wird richtig super lecker
ist wohl perfekt
anfangs wurde genau auf jeden fall und
ich werde euch jetzt zuerst einmal
zeigen wie ich denn bizkit hersteller
und sage ich hier vorne mal die zutaten
für den disput brauch ich für eine prise
salz esslöffel heizwasser etwas man den
extrakt 100 waren bisschen zucker 75 75
gramm stärke und ein teelöffel
backpulver für den diskreten nämlich
zuerst die eier die kommen jetzt in eine
rührschüssel und da ist es ganz wichtig
dass die eier man sie verlange gerührt
wird hier gebe ich jetzt noch eine prise
salz und vier esslöffel heißes wasser
dazu und natürlich von den extrakt und
den zucker und dem maße wittern für etwa
45 minuten gerührt sie sollte wirklich
happy cremig sein und falls ihr ein
handvoll gerät verwendet solltet ihr
vielleicht sogar zehn minuten rühren
[Musik]
jetzt ist die eier mal so fertig hatte
echt gut gemacht die menge mit keine
gesetzlichen unternehmen also mail
stärker und backpulver und hebt die
zutaten und das ganze kommt es erst mal
durch justiz damit einfach die klümpchen
zu schwinden
[Musik]
und wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr auch für
ihn ein bisschen zitronenschale
abschnitt mit rein geben ich finde das
passt perfekt zu einer sommer tourte
[Musik]
die masse fülle jetzt in einen
vorbereiteten backing den habe ich
bereits auf 26 zentimeter durchmesser
eingestellt dann vorsichtig verteilen
und wo kommt das wird jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 170 grad ober
unterhitze für etwa 30 bis 35 minuten
[Musik]
der witwe des gebacken und nach komplett
abgekürzt nach dem backen habe ich ihnen
direkt mit einem back from messer vom
rand gelöst das heißt den part hatte ich
schon erledigt und ihn dann einfach
komplett abkühlen lassen
jetzt kann ich ihnen aus der backform
herausnehmen und stürzt ihn jetzt
einfach auf einen topf mit erfahrung
[Musik]
den ständig jetzt kurz zur seite und
zeigt euch mal die zutaten für die
füllung für die aprikosen füllung
brauchst 400 gramm aprikosen 200
milliliter wasser 15 gramm gaga und 100
sekunden zum würfeln und für die
befüllung 400 gramm proben werden mit
200 milliliter wasser ein päckchen gaga
also wie das sonst in gramm und 30 zum
zucker weil die brombeeren sehr sauer
sind
ich fange jetzt zuerst einmal mit
aprikosen schulung an
das heißt wer die jetzt halbieren und
den kern herausnehmen und die aprikosen
dann pürieren zum pürieren gebe ich
jetzt hier einfach noch wasser mit dazu
dann geht es ein bisschen einfacher
[Musik]
jetzt kommt das buch püree in einen
kleinen topf da kommt das ag mit dazu
und bis fröhlich des kurs klümpchen 21
und lass dir mischung aufkochen und zwei
minuten lang sport und kochen und
während die füllung hier kocht kann ich
schon mal die bestellung machen und sie
geht eben genauso jetzt auch wieder
agatha und natürlich jetzt was beide
aufkochen und dann zwei minuten
sprudelnd kochen
mal gucken wer schneller ist von euch
beiden
[Musik]
das hoch bei ist jetzt gekocht jetzt
will ich es um damit einfach ein
bisschen schneller abkühlt dafür gebe
ich jetzt in zwei tiefe täler und für
den afrika gebe ich jetzt noch die 100
gramm aprikosen gibt auch bereits fein
gewürfelt habe die kontamination dann
stelle ich das kurz zur seite und kam
auch die bomben umfüllen und auch die
zur seite stellen und die lasse ich dann
abkühlen bis sie etwa handwarmen sind
und solange zeige ich es schon mal die
zutaten die ich für die creme benötigen
für die creme fracht 250 gramm
magazin.com schlagsahne meint er zu
seiner tat 250 gramm magerquark etwas
vanille exakt den saft einer halben
zitrone und setz dich gramm futter zu
kommen
jetzt nehme ich zuerst die mascarpone
und gibt sie in eine große schüssel dann
rührig die kurzkrimis flüge dann ganz
langsam die planer dazu
[Musik]
von jetzt an apart mehr dazu und man
keinen krieg gegen schweiz schlagen die
zahl natürlich ist kurz zur seite und
gebe den quark in eine demokratische
wird da kommt man in extrakt ob so etwas
zitronensaft statt butter zucker und die
zutaten werden jetzt auch kurz zurück
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die creme unter die sahne
unterheben
[Musik]
die creme ständig jetzt kurz kühl und
warten muss bis die bomber und aprikosen
füllung abgebildet jetzt kann die farbe
gefüllt werden ich habe schon mal einmal
durchgeschnitten und der ich heute
irgendwie nicht so ganz schön geworden
deswegen bietet improvisiert das macht
nichts sagt nicht was ich falsch gemacht
habe denn ich habe ihn gemacht wie immer
aber was soll's ich wollte ihn
eigentlich dreimal durchschneiden also
wenn feucht reimer geht und macht es
gerne bei mir ging das jetzt nicht aber
wir retten den jetzt jetzt gebe ich ein
bisschen creme hier rein dann
verstreicht gesehen so dass der boden
einfach ein bisschen bedeckt ist dann
kommt diese fortbildung drüber und dann
ist es ganz wichtig dass sie eben nicht
so warm ist dann schmilzt der die sahne
ich hab noch mit der füllung in bis hin
zu gut gemeint aber den rest werde ich
einfach verwenden was wir nicht brauchen
werden der frucht einlade machen und die
einfrieren und irgendwann bei einer
anderen karte einfach weiter benutzen
das wird ein bisschen marmoriert und
dann könnte auch noch die sonne drauf
geben heißt jetzt müsst ihr die hälfte
der wanne etwa verbrauchen
da ich jetzt keinem dritteln des kit
boden habe weil es jetzt einfach
amaranthine cache zu nehmen und damit
die erste schicht bedeckt
[Musik]
darüber kommen gibt eine weitere schicht
sahne und ihr werdet auch vorzüglich
verteilt und dann gebe ich auch hier die
aprikosen stift rüber und mama
[Musik]
jetzt kommt noch der torten deckel drauf
und dann muss ich die torte kühlen für
mindestens 4 stunden gerne auch über
nacht und dann wird er nicht
[Musik]
meine platte durfte über nach dem
kühlschrank stehen gestern was einfach
zu spät und ich wollte heute ganz in
ruhe auskurieren
jetzt werde ich erstmal den westring
löwen dass die torte schon auf eine
tortenplatte gesetzt 200 gramm sahne
steif geschlagen mit zwei teelöffeln und
dann ab und wird die torte kompletter
mit einem streifen vom dekoriert vater
nimmt jetzt ein paar manche fleckchen
ich hab ein paar bp stücke rom bern und
aprikosen und die komplett auf die torte
dick
[Musik]
jetzt ist jetzt hat es fertig und darf
probiert werden murat steht schon in den
startlöchern aber muratow bis heute
leider die nummer drei ja wir haben
heute mit ins boot
genau und weist der bürgermeister von
oberndorf am neckar und das sieht
bürgermeister
am besten kommt einfach beide zu mir
nehme ich heute zu besuch wollen mal
gucken was die fälle denn so alles macht
jetzt fragt ihr euch wahrscheinlich
warum nicht der bürgermeister auf marc
witte der war schon da und oberndorf am
neckar ganz einfach weiter unser
onlineshop und das heißt wir sind auch
dort vertreten und von daher habe heute
von gesucht da dieses übrigens
deprimierend weil ich glaube bis jetzt
hat in seinem ganzen simons videos
gleich mal ein oder zwei leute die nicht
nur grad warm probiert mit komplexer
wird der morast und oben doch amerika
auf sieben jahren gewohnt habe mich
rausgeworfen haben es müsste ja vom
himmel seit 16 jahren sind inzwischen
zwei jahren aber so leckere top habe ich
noch nie sagen angela merkel zu sagen
[Gelächter]
ich wollte hier ganz kurz mit moratti
muss weiter warten denn das dritte stück
brauchtum fotografieren aber wirklich so
klar da wird ja jeder packt im
sonnenpark
daran scheinen wirklich das größte
problem ist bei 800 oder da ist man
immer gleich das ganze stücke und falls
jetzt auch lust bekommen hat auf diese
torte dann schaut's aus belize welt
vorbei update de da gibt's das ganze
rezept noch mal zum ausdrucken und euch
wünsche ich viel spaß und nachmachen und
lieben grüßen oberrauch genau liebe
grüße nach oberndorf an alle am neckar
auch wenn das am neckar genau
und ja auch noch eine schöne zeit
[Musik]